わからないしてですよろしくお願いします
まず最初に
皆さん
ご自身の故郷ちょっと頭の中に
イメージしてもらっても
いいでしょうか
そんなに時間はないんですよ
多分色んな情景が浮かんでいると思います
つい最近
自分には分佐藤がないんだ
そんなことをおっしゃる方とお会いする機会がありました
その方は両親の都合で
幼い頃から引っ越しが大
同じ街に長く住むことなく大人になったので復帰
いまだにこう思い入れを持ってここが故郷だよって言える町がない
そんなことをおっしゃっていません
でも僕はちょっと思う
うるさとって
いくつになっても
あとからでも
作れるんじゃないか
今回僕がお話しさせてもらうわ
すまずに降る里を作る方法
そんな
僕は今東京に住んでいるんですけどももともとの生まれは大阪で大阪で育ちました
ですが大学に入学したのをきっかけにこの長野県に
移り住み一人暮らしが始まりました
そして大学院を卒業するまでの6年間をこの長野県で暮らしていました
休んでるや
まあたぶん多くの方が今思っていただいたと思うんですけども
この僕が学生時代に過ごした
名波の件での6年間っていうのは
本当に今思うとただ身の回りの生活をしていただけ
すごくちょっと悪いかするとただ過ぎ去っていった6年間
そんな
学生生活でした
これ
入学直後の僕なんですけども
6年間長野県に住んでいて
松本城にも善光寺にも一回も言ったことなかったんです
大開口6年間ずっとニヤニヤしてさせました
ていました
そのぐらいん自分が住んでいる街なのに興味を持とうともしないし
まあそもそも関心を寄せることがないそんな大学生だったんですが
そんな学生がいが社会入れて長野を離れ
都会に行くと
いろんな人に言われるんですね長野から来たよって言うと
あー信州と言えばお蕎麦でしょう側かどこの店美味しいのとか
善光寺ってあれは凄い立派な建物ですよねとか
でもまぁ一切答えられないですね僕は何も知らない
これはまずいなと
まずいというかちょっと恥ずかしいなもったいない6年間を過ごしたなぁ
思うようになって
ちょっとこんなことを考えるようになりました
もう一度新種に通ってみよう
もう一度住んでみようっていうのはなかなかハードルが高かったんですが
休み乗り降りをしてもう一度通うことができるんじゃないか
そうすることで学生時代にわからなかったわかろうとしなかった長野県の魅力を再発見
できるんじゃないかなと
考えています
どうせそういうことをやるんだから
自分がはっきりした長野県のステージなところとか
面白いましょう
インターネットを通じて発信しようっていうことも
同時に
始めました
そうすることで自分の頭の中の整理にもなるし
まだ長野県のがでよく知らない人に対して何か知ってもらうきっかけにあるんじゃない
かと
思ったんです
実際こういうですねまあいわゆるブログサービスといわれる
ものを使ってまぁ勝手にですね僕の独断で長野浦里グランというか勝手にやってること
だって
長野ウラドオリっていう単位量だけつけて一気を綴るように長野県のいろんな物を見て
だいたい月1回ぐらいのペースで
信州のいろんなところを訪れ
そこで見たもの
感じたものとか
肘としてい
実際にやっぱり着てみるとすごく面白くて
こんなことも知らなかったんだっていうことがたくさんあって
毎回来る度に驚かされていますちょっと
一例を挙げますと
日本で一番海から遠い地点に行ってきた
これ時下に今のブログの中で昨年に公開した記事の一つなんですか
日本で一番海から遠い地点で実は長野県内にあるんですね
なんとなく
北海道が真ん中にありそうだなっていうイメージ
あると思うんですよ実は長野県の佐久市の山の中にそのポイントが
あります
じゃあ実際行って見ようと思っ
行ってきました
こんなやまなかった
くっています
これぽくんですけどもこの写真を実際に本記事の中で掲載している私に何かあっ
これもですね
三脚を置いて
カメラをセットしてする2人もあるとっているんですね
こんなことをしながらだいたい
1時間ぐらいは
山道を
歩いて行くとですね
日本で一番海から遠いして言うこのように
者もするしもあるのでいけば皆さんとか分かりますというところにたどり着きますここ
ちなみに神奈川県の海岸線から
114.862キロメートル直線距離で離れているそうで
ちまぐり日本ではそこが一番ライフのポイントになるそうです
ここからは完全にちょっと余談なんですがその子の写真のパソから
114.862km いった神奈川チェーンの階段線
いったいどんなところかというとこんなところなりますん
ここまでをひっくるめて僕は一つの生地としてこんなところがあるよと紹介しました
やっぱり長野県もたくさん面白い場所ってのがあってそういう場所を見るとどんどん人
に伝えたくなるし
言いたくなります
で
日本で一番海から遠い地点でなかなかにマニアックで地味なポイントをどうやったら
より多くの人に楽しんでいってもらえるかなっていうことを考えて工夫するしだんだん
そう工夫することも面白く感じられるようになってきました
他にもいろんなところに行きまして
一応駅言われるようなこれ jr飯田線の田本駅っていうところ
気に入ったりとかですね
大晦日の善光寺に行って除夜の鐘をつくって言うになりました
これ実際108人限定ですけどならんからつかしてもらえるんです
だんだん
色なども紹介していくと何か一つの場所を紹介するだけでは物足りなくなっていて
これ舞台は東京なんですけども
東京で
長野県77市町村すべての出身者を探してみようという企画をブログを通じて行ったり
もするようになりました
これちょっとマニアックで申し訳ないんですけども
謎解きイベントっていうのを長野県で開催しました
ちょっと馴染みがない人にはちょっとよくわからないと思うんですけど今と会を中心に
脱出ゲームとか
謎解きゲームって言われるイベントが結構宮6になっていて
クイズとかパズルとか暗号を解きながらゴールを目指すみたいな
そういうサブカルチャーというのはイベントが
やっているので長は生のがやってみようということで僕が主催で開催しました
なんで僕はこういうことを開催したかというと
すごく理由は単純で
そんなブームの流れにのって
僕自身がはまってだからです
わかります僕なんか今やりたいことがあったらもう
長野でやればいい
そんな風に思えるようになってきたんです東京に住んでいるので
まあいろんな効率を考えて東京のがいいんですけどもそれでも生のほうがやりやすいっ
て思えるような考え方ができるようになってきた
ほかにもトークライブっていうのを主催したりとかですね
出版に携わるなんていうことも
させてもらったりもしました
そんなことができるようになったも
僕は長野県内にたくさんの水愛とか
友人が
this たからなんですね
ブログをやってるんですけどなるべく多くの人に言いました
そうすると面白がってくれる人もいるしああもう知ってりはのゴムでしょうって言って
くれる人もいい
長野に来るたびにちょっとずつですよ
人と人との関わりが深まっていくのをジワジワと感じられる
これ写真が長野市の
門前町といわれる善光寺の周辺の
街なんですけども今僕平次が昼間にここあること
このは構えさんまたしてるんですか
後編今回はいつまでいるんですか声をかけてもらったんですよね
これって今僕が住んでいる東京の女ブログじゃ絶対にありえないと思うんですね
簡単に言うと僕は
中にキーば消化できたんです
うるさとっていろんな考え方があると思いますけど僕は
自分が安心してみようを受ける町のことそして自分を受け入れてくれる街のことを言う
んじゃないかというふうに思っています
ちょっとカッコせいだ言い方をするとですね僕がこうやって
ブログでいろいろ発信していたことという正
地域へのラブレターだったんだなっていうふうに今は
そう思えるようになりましたね
中のいろんなところを訪れ
しかも何度も来るそれをなんか
東京に住んでるのに
長野に住んでいるかのようにブログで発信し続ける
よっぽど会津長野が好きなんだかっていう
永野均いる人にじわじわじわじわ伝わっていって
ちょっとだけ長野っていう輪の中に入れてもらえるようになった
そして
長野県ふるさとって言っていいんじゃないかなっていうふうに思うようになりました
そんな
流れの中で
一つ
すごく大事なことがあるんだなっていうことに
気づかされました今日はそれを最後にお話
終わりたいと思うんですけどもその大事なことというものですね
故郷デー
役も担うということだ
僕は山そっと
受け入れてくれるっていう言葉をさらっと使ったんですけども
故郷大テーマにした時
受け入れてくれるっていうのは決しておもてなしをしてくれるっていう意味ではないと
思うんですね
確かに
居酒屋とかバーン
5件常連客になると居心地もいいし居場所もあるし
小さい故郷のように感じられることもあると思います
でももう少しその単位を大きくして
町は地域って言う
店でのふるさとって考えると
お客さんではダメ
地域や街にとっての仲間にならないといけない
あの人率は町にとってこんなことをしてくれる人だとか
もしくは街にとって待ちにと町の中であの人がこんなことをしている人だろう
いうことが認められてよそ者の自分が地域とか街に受け入れられるんじゃないかなと
思います役割っていろんな種類があって
自分の店を出店しますけどすごく立派な役割だと思いますし
両親のお世話をしています子育てをしています
これも役割だと思います
何か自分の持っている経験とかノウハウを伝承する伝える教えるって言うことも役割だ
と思いますしもちろんその地域の企業に勤めることも役割だと思います
でもそれと同時に
インターネットでその地域の魅力を発信することも
発信し続ければ
すごく細やかですけど
役割になるんです
僕は
今
生まれ小巨という意味での大阪っていう風里と
この長野県の新種という故郷
の2つ
すごく賑やかで早くから都市化された
大阪と自然豊ら親子5
その2つのコントラストを楽しみながら
東京で暮らしています
冒頭で言ったように
自分には故郷がないんだよっていう人とかもしくは
かつての木みたいに住んでいた過去実績技術はあるんだけどイマイチ地域に触れ合う
ことなんか変わることなく興味を持つことなく過ごしてしまった思いがある人
もっと言えばそのどちらでもないけどなんか旅行で一旦はマジちょっと居心地がいい気
がしたんだよなっていう想いがあったりする人
まずはかやっぺに
なかなか通うって
ないと思うんですけどそれを敢えてやってみる
そしてインターネットを通じてその地域の魅力を発信する
なんだろこのインターネットどうこうっていう部分はなくてもいいです
何か通うなかでその街や地域の
魅力に気付い
その中で
役割を担うことができればまたもう一つあなたのふるさとか
生まれるんじゃないかなと僕は思って
そうするとちょっと豊かな人生になると思う
それにそんなにハードルも高くないと思うのでもし何かピンと来るところがあった人は
是非実践してもらえればなと思っています
以上はお話でしたありがとうございました